[Musica]
la comunicazione che mi ha preceduto ha
fatto vedere Chiaramente come
lo studio degli esopianeti rappresenti
una sfida estremamente affascinante però
ancora molto distante dall'idea che si
possano sfruttare in qualche modo che ci
si possa arrivare In tempi rapidi anche
se quasi sicuramente rappresenteranno il
futuro dell'umanità magari non di questa
era
C'è da dire che esistono delle sfide
altrettanto importanti e interessanti
nel nostro pianeta
La terra è tutt'altro che scoperta e
tutt'altro che studiata e capita
investigata e la maggior parte della
terra rimane ancora fondamentalmente un
mistero da un punto di vista scientifico
Soprattutto la parte coperta dalle acque
è sotto le acque in particolare nelle
grandi profondità oceaniche che
rappresentano la parte più vasta del
pianeta che noi potremmo trovare liendo
pianeti cioè quelle ecosistemi complessi
e distanti lontani che non sono stati
ancora né capiti da investigati a
sufficienza e che però rappresentano
forse la quantità più importante della
biodiversità che deve essere ancora
studiare
parleremo infatti di Piane abissali
parleremo di camini idrotermali
parleremo dei Laghi sub glaciali del
dell'Antartide parleremo delle grandi
fosse come l'abisso Challenge nella
fossa delle Marianne sono tutti ambienti
che fondamentalmente stanno al di sotto
delle acque l'acqua fondamentalmente
rappresenta il 70% del pianeta il 70%
del pianeta è coperto dalle acque e di
questo
e di questo
l'83% rappresenta fondamentalmente il la
parte dell'oceano che ancora dobbiamo
investigare vedete tutto questo Azzurro
l'83% di questo azzurro rappresenta la
zona meno conosciuta del pianeta
al di sotto dei 4000 6000 metri di
profondità
si chiama Piana abissale e l'ambiente
fondamentalmente è più grande che esiste
sulla terra e qui ci troveremo degli
ambienti che possono essere ricondotti
anche a situazioni che potremmo trovare
sul mondiale di ma neanche troppo extra
solari Anche semplicemente per esempio
nelle lune di alcuni pianeti che ci
girano intorno quindi la Piana abissale
è il primo grande deserto biologico Come
si pensava una volta
il deserto più grande per immenso che
esista sulla terra che secondo i
ricercatori di un secolo fa 50 anni fa
rappresentava semplicemente un posto
dove ci potevano essere al massimo dei
batteri Adesso invece abbiamo scoperto
che nella piana abissale
Esiste la vita questa è un esempio una
tigna con questi tentacoli lunghissimi
che sta proprio sul pavimento sui 4/5
mila metri di profondità però abbiamo
lungo la scarpata continentale che ci
accompagna verso l'abisso delle
formazioni coralline che non hanno
niente da invidiare alle pareti con la
linea superficiali si chiamano barriere
coralline profonde o fredde per
costruire una barriera corallina come
questa ci vogliono millenni perché la
capacità di crescita del corallo di
profondità non è uguale a quella del
corallo e superficie delle materie
tropicali ma una crescita lentissima
però c'è una diversità incredibile un
ambiente Diciamo che ha un'età
incredibile e purtroppo è sottoposto a
un grosso rischio di eliminazione da
parte della pesca di profondità che
arriva fino a 2000 metri con le reti a
strascico
troviamo poi dei fondi duri come questi
sono colonizzati da questi invertebrati
che creano queste specie di di foreste
fantastiche sempre al buio sempre in
acqua estremamente profonde
poi vediamo gli adattamenti alla piana
abissale vera e propria Dove esiste
questo gigantesco abissale perché
conviene essere più grandi e più
compatti e più robusti per resistere
alle pressioni di centinaia di atmosfere
che assume questa forma ad uovo proprio
per resistere alle pressioni e a destra
invece abbiamo un isotono crostaceo che
ha questa specie di corazza incredibile
Una specie di corazza medievale che lo
rende In pratica immune da dalle immense
pressioni
c'è però il mondo del del fondo diciamo
proprio del pavimento della Piana
abissale che è ricchissima di batteri e
permette la vita come vedete a certi
olosure che anche se sono di colori così
vivaci ma nessuno le potrà vedere perché
siamo nel buio più profondo
i pesci rappresentano la comunità ittica
forse più straordinaria del pianeta
perché comunicano tra di loro attraverso
la luce organi bioluminescenti che si
chiamano fotofori che Gli permettono in
qualche modo di comunicare tra le specie
per la ricerca del padre o per la
ricerca delle prede o per difendersi dai
predatori e tutto un linguaggio basato
sulla luce nel buio
perfino le meduse riescono ad avere
delle specie delle lampadine al loro
interno
3.700 metri di profondità
però l'aspetto più interessante al punto
di vista scientifico che è stato
recentemente reso pubblico è che è stata
fatta una ricerca sul DNA ambientale
cioè il DNA che può essere
prelevato direttamente sull'ambiente non
si va a cercare l'organismo Ma si
prevano parti di sedimento partiti acqua
e si analizza il DNA che gli organismi
hanno rilasciati E da questo Si risale
poi alla biodiversità del sistema Ebbene
nelle Piana abissali di tutto il mondo
sono stati raccolti centinaia di
campioni che hanno dimostrato che nelle
Piane abissali esiste una quantità di
batteri 10 volte superiore a quella
delle acque superficiali esiste una
quantità impressionante di specie che
non sono state mai classificate da
nessuno tre quarti Delle specie trovate
non sono ancora classificabili neanche
da un punto di vista sistematico
quindi si sta scoprendo che la Piana
abissale che fino a qualche decennio fa
era considerata il deserto dell'oceano
in realtà potrebbe nascondere la più
alta biodiversità in assoluto
se si potesse camminare o passare
Diciamo attraverso queste immense
pianure abissali alla fine troveremo le
cosiddette grandi dorsali oceaniche sono
Queste strisce rosse
che rappresentano delle vere e proprie
ferite della crosta terrestre sono i
punti di collegamento tra le grandi
zolle e dove l'attività vulcanica è
altissima ci sono vulcani perennemente
attivi sottomarini ovviamente alcuni che
possono addirittura emergere e queste
sono zone abbastanza difficili per la
vita apparentemente sui versanti di
queste dorsali ci sono poi fenomeni di
degassamento Cioè praticamente spruzzi
continui di vapori soprattutto a base di
composti solforati che danno luogo
ai cosiddetti camini idrotermali questi
uno degli ambienti che potremmo definire
assolutamente infernale perché ci sono
temperature qui intorno dell'Ordine dei
400 gradi ci sono vapori di zolfo che
annientano la presenza dell'ossigeno c'è
il buio assoluto e ci sono pressioni di
centinaia e centinaia di atmosfere in un
posto come questo uno non andrebbe mai a
cercare la vita e invece è proprio nei
camini idrotermali che la biodiversità
esprime diciamo una delle sue più grandi
manifestazioni questi camini idrotermali
sono riempiti di vita come vedete spugne
Vivaldi
vermi che incrostano tutti quei
diciamo quei tubicini bianchi che si
vedono questi grandi edifici addirittura
che si formano sono Infatti costruiti
dai minerali e fuoriescono E infatti
costruiti addirittura dai costruttori
vedete si vedono benissimo i granchi che
si arrampicano su questa struttura
Non solo ma vediamo anche animali che si
muovono si vedono dei gamberetti che si
muovono intorno a temperature altissime
e con bassissima concentrazione di
ossigeno poi naturalmente più ci si
allontana più si trovano anche i pesci
tra gli organismi più sorprendenti ci
sono questi sono policheti crostanti che
hanno questo colore bellissimo non per
farsi vedere perché nessuno le vede
laggiù nel buio Ma perché sono hanno i
loro tessuti con una concentrazione
altissima di emoglobina che appunto gli
danno il colore rosso perché l'ossigeno
è particolarmente rarefatto Qui la vita
si svolge in maniera completamente
diversa che nel nelle zone diciamo dove
prevale la fotosintesi e quindi si parte
da materiale vegetale che poi
rappresenta la base della catena
alimentare qui la catena alimentare è
rappresentata dai batteri che si nutrono
di solfuri che sfrutta l'energia chimica
dei solfuri per crescere in maniera
incredibilmente ampia intensa e questi
batteri rappresentano il cibo che tiene
in piedi tutta la struttura atrofica del
sistema
Uno potrebbe dire Sì ma ce ne saranno
due o tre di questi sistemi particolari
no come vedete le dorsali sono piene di
ecosistemi di questo tipo li Stiamo
scoprendo di continuo ce n'è perfino uno
davanti a Capo Palinuro da noi
non sappiamo neanche che ruolo
potrebbero avere per i garantiscili nei
quali questi ecosistemi sconosciuti non
sono mai stati considerati per esempio
il ciclo del carbonio che è uno dei cibi
più importanti che oggi dovrebbe essere
conosciuto a fondo per capire meglio il
riscaldamento globale
parliamo anche degli ambienti più
profondi mentre le dorsali sono dei
rilievi le fosse adali si chiamano fossi
ad Ali perché sono dellate cioè del
mondo dell'aldilà quindi sono gli
ambienti che venivano considerati più
vicini fondamentalmente all'inferno
si tratta di un canyon
di 2.600 km che in pratica ha delle
Fosse che arrivano fino a 11 km di
profondità a 11 km di profondità i pesci
non ci sono più il loro limite nel dal
punto di vista batimetrico finisce
intorno a 8000 metri le pressioni sono
eccessive e le strutture dei pesci non
reggerebbero a queste pressioni
Però in fondo alla fossa Challenge che
appunto l'abisso Challenger c'è ancora
vista c'è non ci sono comunità
batteriche estremamente complesse con
un'altissima biodiversità che di nuovo
sfrutta i solfuri ma sfrutta anche
l'idrogeno generato da fenomeni detti
serpentinizzazione delle rocce che
mettono idrogeno che viene trasformato
in metano dai batteri
qualcuno di questi batteri sfrutta
Addirittura il metano altri producono
idrocarburi come ammortizzatori
molecolari delle pressioni e i loro
metaboliti Vengono mangiati da altri
batteri e ci sono delle Rotture giganti
e si nutrono di tutti questi batteri e
così si sviluppa di nuovo un ecosistema
Complesso dove praticamente non si
immaginava che ci fosse una tale
biodiversità
ci sono degli adattamenti incredibili
come questi di un gamberetto e arriva a
vivere fino in fondo alla fossa e che è
riuscito nel corso dell'evoluzione a
costruirsi un esoscheletro cioè uno
scheletro interno rivestito di alluminio
un gel di idrossido di alluminio che li
crea una specie di corazza di tipo
metallico come se fosse quasi un
animaletto bionico
quindi i modelli di adattamento a
condizione estreme sulla terra quasi non
hanno limiti si trovano praticamente
ecosistemi comunità e in ambienti e sono
talmente estremi da utilizzare benissimo
come modelli per la ricerca divisa in
altri mondi in altri pianeti
l'ultimo degli endopianeti di cui voglio
parlare è il lago postok che è un lago
sub glaciale sub glaciale vuol dire vuol
dire Resta al di sotto della calotta
ghiacciata e l'antartide 4 km di crosta
ghiacciata al di sotto di questa c'è il
lago un lago grande come la regione
Campania lungo 250 km Largo 50 profondo
centinaia e centinaia di metri
ha una caratteristica particolare
è isolato dal mondo esterno da milioni
di anni Probabilmente uno due tre
Qualcuno dice 15 milioni di anni quindi
se c'è la vita in questo lago ormai ha
seguito un percorso parallelo un
percorso che non ha più niente a che
vedere con l'evoluzione degli ultimi
milioni di anni
Ebbene nel 2013 è stato perforato
il grande spessore dei quattro
chilometri di ghiaccio da un equipe di
scienziati che è arrivato
all'acqua praticamente di questo lago e
ha fatto dei prelievi ha fatto dei premi
e ha trovato dei batteri che sono
sconosciuti e quindi non riconoscibili a
nessun batterio terrestre quindi è come
se si trattasse di batteri alieni perché
sicuramente
milioni di anni si sono evoluti in
maniera totalmente
separata diciamo dal resto
dell'evoluzione
C'è da dire che il modello di vita nel
lago vostro che richiama soprattutto per
chi conosce l'astronomia la struttura di
certe lune come la luna di Europa
che è praticamente una luna che è
caratterizzata per l'appunto dalla costa
ghiacciata e al suo interno sembra che
esista acqua liquida quindi avremo
un'analogia estremamente stretta tra
quello che è il lago vostro che i laghi
subito lasciali che non è l'unico
dellattartide praticamente e non un
esopianeta ma un corpo Celeste che
appartiene al nostro stesso sistema
solare
quindi c'è molto lavoro da fare
Sicuramente sugli esopianeti Ma dobbiamo
ancora conoscere molta parte del nostro
pianeta abbiamo visto almeno la metà
C'è da dire che
l'uomo non si è comportato benissimo con
la parte conosciuta del pianeta e gli
effetti si vedono ovviamente dappertutto
i suoi residui suoi rifiuti le
microplastiche e l'inquinanti si
ritrovano anche nella fossa delle
Marianne si ritrovano nelle Piane
abissali si ritrovano negli organismi di
tutti i tipi si ritrovano ai ghiacci
dell'Antartide probabilmente aver
perforato l'ago posto che esserci
arrivati con una con una trivella al lo
ha contaminato e quindi lo ha messo in
contatto con il mondo mentre invece era
stato isolato per un milione di anni
Quindi bisognerà in qualche modo
approcciare sia agli endopienti sia gli
esopianeti in maniera diversa
sicuramente più rispettosa rispetto a
quella che abbiamo fatto fino ad oggi
Grazie per l'attenzione
[Applauso]